et comme on le disait voilà on fait
toujours un petit un petit prélève ou on
discute vous avez vu dans le titre ce
soir on va parler de
Caleb Houston le joueur freshman
canadien qui joue à Michigan cette année
qui est attendu top
Paris espienne qui était très très côté
qui devait être le leader star jeune de
Michigan et finalement qui quand il y a
une première saison compliquée donc
on va regarder un petit peu le profil de
ce jour qu'est-ce qu'il a pu nous
montrer
avec l'équipe de Michigan et qu'est-ce
qu'on pourrait comment on pourrait le
projeter pour la suite en NBA parce que
c'est une saison trompe l'oeil est-ce
qu'il est vraiment du potentiel ou pas
donc voilà
mais bon avant ça comme d'hab laisse on
laisse toujours 5 10 minutes
on discute est-ce que tiens est-ce qu'il
y a un joueur qui
vous a marqué cette semaine et skin
équipe qui vous a plu cette semaine
est-ce que un match que vous avez pu
voir qu'ils avaient kiffer qui vous a
énervé ou une déclare ou quelque chose
n'importe quoi
vous voulez parler de ça je prends le
temps je peux faire ça
pour faire le coucou
bonsoir à tous Alors vous avez vu que la
petite plaise vieille personne oblige
alors là on se couvre un petit peu j'ai
fait j'ai fait le mec j'ai coupé le
chauffage chez moi c'est petit feu de
cheminée je suis en T-shirt un petit
plaid voilà tout est fait il manque une
petite tisane et j'aurais vraiment la
pâte plis il n'a pas de pluie pour pour
laver à 21h10 là je sors de mon souper
évidemment et puis voilà la petite
camomille et je serai au lit d'ici une
heure
bon ben écoutez comme je vois pas
énormément de monde dans le chat et
Chris c'est pas très grave on va pouvoir
commencer tranquillement du coup sur
Caleb juste un directement
comment je vous ai préparé ça comme
d'habitude un petit profil statistique
on va la regarder s'affiche en burger
que je vous prépare ici là
d'ailleurs vous dites assez amuse
qu'elle est pas trop fort je vais la
coupure comme ça ce sera bon
le but c'est quand même qu'on m'entendre
hop là
OK
normalement c'est bon là-dessus alors
qu'elle est biouston pour ceux qui sont
pas
qui ne sont pas familiers du profil vous
le voyez dans notre Big Bang c'est notre
big board envergure que vous pouvez
retrouver du coup ici directement
hop là pour pouvoir voir où est-ce qu'on
classe les joueurs en fonction de leur
potentialité en fonction de leur
efficacité et cetera et vous avez du
coup les différents avis des membres
d'envergure
pour l'instant on est cinq à l'avoir
fait Alex Manu ben Alan et moi-même qui
suis le plus à droite ici ton message
j'aurais assez régulièrement vous voyez
on essaie de le faire à peu près tous
les mois moi je l'ai fait il y a 6 jours
vous pouvez retrouver
notre Top 30 voir pour certains un peu
plus et live mecs qui sont allés 60 80 à
peu près je me suis arrêté voilà aux
portes du Top 40 et fous je complète ça
faut que je prenne le temps de compléter
ça mais ça va arriver et à chaque fois
quand vous cherchez un joueur voyez où
est-ce que les autres membres l'ont
placé
et vous voyez si si je prends l'exemple
de Moussa diabète français par exemple
s'il est monté ou s'il était sensu par
rapport à la dernière fois dans dans
chaque board donc tout à gauche vous
avez le consensus la moyenne globalement
la moyenne pondérée de nos classements
pour avoir un board en vergure que vous
pouvez comparer après ce qui se fait sur
Internet salut Je te gueule ça va ben
écoute moi de mon côté ça va bien ça va
bien un petit live le lundi soir
supplémentaire donc
impeccable écoute j'espère que toi aussi
ça t'a passé une bonne journée
et puis voilà on se retrouve pour parler
de de Caleb Houston donc du coup notre
ami Caleb Houston où est-ce qu'il se
situe alors j'en profite pour faire vite
fait ça
voilà où est-ce qu'il s'y situé alors on
regarde dans le consensus il est attendu
top 10 et nous chez nous il est placé
20e dans le consensus alors vous voyez
il y a 20e consensus d'origine
canadienne il est positionné en tant
qu'allier 19 ans donc ça me touche un
freshman
au plus haut au plus haut notre ami
palais biouston alors ouais ce que je
vais le trouver sur d'autres challenge
je pense moi peut-être même pas en
mettre des zoomer un petit peu pour voir
ça
alors ouais au plus haut il est 18e
c'est chez Alexandre chez Manu vous
l'avez 19e chez Alan vous avez 25 chez
Ben 24 et chez moi vous l'avez 26e
comment est-ce que ça a évolué un petit
peu sa cote il a pas bougé de place pour
pour Manu pour Alex pardon pour Manu et
pour Alan ben là un peu descendu et moi
vous voyez le moins 17 terrible terrible
coup dur pour que les Houston qui a
drastiquement chuté chez moi je l'avais
mis 9 lors de mon premier mon premier
board je voulais laisser le bénéfice du
doute au joueur qui connaissait un début
de saison très compliqué mais je l'avais
bien aimé côté canadien avec l'équipe
U19 et toi aussi il a bien eu des choses
cigales ouais bon bah du coup tant mieux
ça me ça me réconforte dans l'idée que
c'est pas délirant voilà
l'été 9e il a beaucoup chuté parce que
malheureusement
les choses dans lequel je ne croyais pas
se confirme on va pouvoir voir ça
ensemble dans le dans le filmer dans les
stats et les choses dans lesquelles je
voulais croire ne se montre pas donc oui
il y a une saison très compliquée au
global du côté de Michigan mais il y a
quand même des des défauts qui me font
dire que ce joueur n'a pas le potentiel
et ce qu'on était en tout cas n'a pas le
le talent
et le niveau auquel on attendait en
début de saison salut padawan 92 33 et
tu me dis Hugues dans le tête je ne sais
pas si tu sais que je m'appelle Hugues
ou pas en tout cas bien joué
et écoute bienvenue à toi sur sur le
chat bienvenue à toi sur notre chaîne
envergure et j'espère que tu vas pouvoir
passer un
un bon moment notre compagnie donc si on
clique un petit peu maintenant sur le
joueur pour voir
qu'est-ce qu'on en dit qu'est-ce qu'on a
comme information déjà super boulot à
toute la team merci beaucoup c'est très
gentil de ta part je transmettrai je
transmettrai au collègue
on est content de pouvoir proposer un
scooting et pour ton article par jour
différents contenus vidéo podcast et
live du coup avec moi donc donc kiffe
notre aventure envergure et content que
ça te plaise aussi
donc Caleb juste un alors vous voyez on
avait les photos FIBA avec l'équipe U19
canadienne où c'était la star de
l'équipe avec aussi Bénédicte Mathurin
entre autres et
Ryan Neymar le meneur qui joue
maintenant du côté de créteilton et le
petit frère de
de Neymar qui joue du côté de Gonzaga
donc
du côté de Michigan dans les stades
brutes il a started tous les matchs et
cette année il a joué 27 matchs 32
minutes par match qui perd beaucoup avec
beaucoup de déception
il a un volume de tir assez conséquent
il en prend 8,3 par match on voit qu'en
terme d'efficacité pourcentage c'est
très très très très faible 41 % à peine
très peu de 2 3 2 points pardon donc en
gros c'est un tiers de s'étire enfin 40
% de 7 tirer à deux points 46,7 x 46 %,
c'est très faible et à 3 points plus
gros volume 5 tentatives par match pour
36 % ce qui est correct sans être
excellent ce qu'il faut noter on va pas
le regarder là mais ce qu'il faut noter
c'est qu'au début d'année c'était
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de tiré et
plus ça va et mieux vaut plus il
commence à rentrer dans dans son rythme
et puis s'il en est donc voilà il y a un
réel progrès dans la réussite à trois
points de Calais [ __ ] de qui nous
rassure un petit peu parce que c'était
quand même ça
sa carte de visite sa clé pour rentrer
au niveau supérieur ce tir donc
donc voilà et des progrès c'est une
McGregor qui disait qu'il était
complètement perdu sur le terrain ouais
exactement tu as bien suivi le live de
début d'année qu'on avait sur le planète
draft pour les autres qui ne savent pas
qui est McGregor c'est le photographe
officiel de l'équipe de basket de
Michigan c'est un Français qui vit sur
le campus de Michigan et qui est leur
photographe officiel qui a notamment
pris cette magnifique photo faut que
j'essaie de la vouloir trouver en même
temps parce qu'elle est très très très
belle vous inquiétez pas il y a mes
petits qui renversent tout à côté alors
j'ai très peur de taper Hunter Dickinson
et de taper pic parce que ça fait
vraiment très Dick pic à côté donc ça me
fait un peu peur mais on va espérer que
tout se passe bien on va être taper
photographier on va essayer de on va
essayer de pas de pas se planter pour
pas se faire ban par pitié est-ce que je
vais la trouver cette magnifique photo
sinon j'irai sur le Twitter directement
de notre ami McGregor c'est pas très
grave
autant que ça change vous connaissez la
campagne non j'ai pas la voir ne pas
l'avoir pour tant pis on va aller dans
Marc Gregor comme ça
photo voici hop là
voilà cette photo qui est incroyable
bref tout ça pour vous dire c'est le
photographe officiel waouh ok on voit
rien tant pis
ouais c'est le photographe officiel
donc de l'équipe de Michigan qui donc
qui est en courseide à tous les matchs
et qui nous disait lors d'un Planet
draft que Caleb Busta n'était
complètement perdu dans le système de
Michigan que tous ces coéquipiers lui
gueuler dessus et lui demander de
demander de se replacer que Renault le
coach en 5 jours NBA était fou et
engueuler tout le temps son joueur qui
qui était paumé donc voilà la photo
n'hésitez pas faut le McGregor qui fait
un travail exceptionnel et qui me donne
des petites exclusivités
voilà que le joueur était paumé après le
système de Micheline d'un système très
compliqué quand même avec beaucoup de
mouvement de balle beaucoup d'écran
beaucoup de démarcages ont défonce sa
switch et reprend il y a de la route et
tout donc on peut comprendre que pour un
jeune qui débarque
surtout après avoir fait un championnat
du monde
U19 avec du Canada du coup qui a mis
plus de temps à revenir sur le campus et
qui a pris plus de temps à connaître les
systèmes que ce soit un peu difficile
donc voilà il y a combien du salut à toi
qui nous dit sur les 13 derniers matchs
il a 44 % à 3 points 47 % global voilà
c'est ce que ça confirme
ce que je vous disais tout à l'heure
merci de te dire sur de ta part que le
jour est de plus en plus en rythme et de
plus en plus en efficacité ça se voit
dans sa dans son body language dans sa
façon de prendre les tirs dans le fait
qu'il n'hésite plus autant pour pour
déclencher et cetera
et donc il gagne en efficacité tout
simplement
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'on en disait de sur Calais
Houston tout tout tout
alors vous voyez c'était un jour qui
était déjà suivi de dans les U16 il y a
2 ans où il y avait déjà été remarqué
par Antoine Béranger Antoine qui est
notre créateur du site envurger qui a
créé le site envergure.co que vous
retrouvez du coup ici
hop là
et Anthony nous avait déjà dit alors à
l'époque elle est juste il avait mesuré
à 2,05 il a été
il a rétréci on va dire voilà elle a été
mesurée où il le trouvait fluide mobile
qui était très mince qui était pas bon
dans le contact intéressant ça se cette
remarque on regardera dans le site dans
le site dans les vidéos comment ça ça
évoluer je quittons autour du shoot
extérieur ça c'est toujours vrai le
ballon sont très bien des mains bien
qu'un point lentement le camp n'est pas
ses clés pour monter droit
et voilà tout tout tout tout tout tout
tout
et nous disait à la fin j'ai repris les
2 m 05 indiqué par la FIBA me le jour me
semble deux à 3 cm plus petit ben il a
très bien il a très bien vu là il a
l'œil notre ami Antoine Béranger là vous
avez son hâte ici à Leffe FR pour pour
le suivre d'ailleurs si vous voulez
suivre tout le monde d'envergure c'est
pas compliqué
à
je vous les mets tous ici tout
simplement
n'hésitez pas ça permet aux copain de
d'avoir un petit peu de reconnaissance
pour leur travail
donc elle est juste à nous la mesurer à
2 m 03 donc effectivement un peu plus
petit 93 kg
et vous allez avoir un scooting et porte
qui va être réglé par Maxime dans les
prochains dans les prochaines semaines
et ça devrait arriver assez salement
sous peu si on veut regarder dans les
stats avant c'est du joueur avant
d'aller voir son film et de et d'en
discuter vous avez toujours au maths ici
donc je vous les mets
vous avez
Matéo peut explorer on va aller du côté
de Michigan
et qu'est-ce que ça nous dit alors une
équipe avec énormément de jeunes qui
sont arrivés quelques vétérans et les
books entre autres un sauveur sophomore
Hunter de kinson qui est l'homme qu'on
voit
ici qui est le pivot star de l'équipe
qui a le plus de tir et qui a le plus de
responsabilité qui est un pivot assez
traditionnel
qui joue poste bas mais qui monte cette
année qui peut tirer un peu à trois
points à ses côtés post 4 vous avez
notre français Moussa Diabaté qui a fait
un cursus américain qui a joué à la i
AMJ Academy qui t'a laissé devant des
lycée des plus cotés qui s'étonnait
rejoint Michel qui joue post 4 avec les
Wolverine mais qui est amené à être un
pivot à terme et que nous on estime
fortement qu'on a tous en fin de loterie
là où les autres sites
traditionnels de de moque et tout on
parle qu'en fin de premier tour voir ce
mon tour ce qui nous choque un peu hors
chauvénisme dans le joueur a du
potentiel pour devenir un pivot
titulaire NBA et monte grande chose
notamment défensivement
qu'elle est juste un bijoux et liée pour
ce 3 titulaire pour XS le troisième plus
gros volume de l'équipe je prends une
question vite fait de stoïa qui nous
demande qui ne sonne possible de le voir
au NBA écoute
on vit dans une NBA au Udo case du
biquet et draftés au premier tour donc
de là tout est possible
on va dire
Lucas gardien l'an dernier est pris au
second tour avec les pistons en ayant
dominé en une scie et ne joue quasiment
pas si je dis pas de bêtises je pense
qu'il passe son temps angélique Hunter
de kinson c'est à peu près pareil il est
pas très mobile alors comme tu le vois
à 3 points on a 34 % avec un volume qui
augmente au fur et à mesure donc il
montre qu'il est chargé le jeu mais
c'est pas un protecteur de cercle
c'est pas un passeur de fou il a pas un
Dole donc voilà je pense qu'il est assez
anachronique et si jamais il rentrera
une bière ce serait pas la petite porte
et je le vois pas je le vois pas tenir
plus de plus d'un ou deux ans
NBA alors qu'il aura une vraie carrière
en Europe ça se trouve je te dis des
conneries et puis 2000 à Nicolas yakit
mais
je ne pense pas
spatiale la draft sur certains choix
ouais
de toute façon les deux cas du biquet on
sait avec le jazz donné que tu mets du
feu chaque année ils ont un pic 27 28 et
ils prennent à pivot donc ils ont fait
ils ont fait pareil avec
notre ami je vais avoir oublié le nom le
pivot de Yohan c'est qui joue à Chicago
en plus Tony Bradley ils en font ils en
prennent un tous les deux trois ans donc
il y a moyen que cette année leur fasse
encore je ne serai pas je ne serai pas
surpris donc ouais Khaled you stade 3e
volume de l'équipe quand même au mois de
la répartition des tiers il y a très
très très très peu de tiers prix près du
panier près du sale donc dans les lieux
puis il a 62 % de réussite
qui est moyenne ncillet globalement
c'est dans la moyenne entier on voit que
sur la moitié de 7/3 son prix en
réception de parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
démarrage au cercle et l'autre moitié il
se crée un accès Ball en main très peu
de mi distance
très très peu de mi distance chez Caleb
Houston
32,4 % donc il est pas très efficace sur
ce secteur là et vous voyez quand il les
prend c'est des tirs en pull-up donc
c'est plus des tirs qui vont être forcés
plus que des tirs qui va lui-même
prendre quelques pull-up en sortie de
d'écran lorsqu'il va jouer un pick and
rolls qui lui arrive pas très souvent à
être honnête du côté de Michigan
quelques pull-up après pick
& roll où il y a de l'espace dans une
défense qui d'Europe et il peut
sanctionner c'est le il va être en
réussite mais c'est vraiment à ça
descotique comme volume et après 60 % de
cette série à 3 points 37 % de réussite
mais comme nous la disto il y a commis
un peu plus haut que il était à je
reprends tes chiffres parce que ils sont
plus fiables que mais une approximation
de ma part il faut que tu m'as dit 40 %
hop là 44 % à 3 points c'est ça 44 %
uniquement du catch and shoot
sur les dernières sur les dernières
semaines ensuite un fruit sur white à 35
% ça a l'air faible comme ça mais quand
on voit que le joueur va quasiment
jamais au Cercle ça veut dire que quand
il y va
il arrive quand même à trouver des
fautes donc ça c'est intéressant il met
78 % de ses de ses tentatives à lancer
au lancer France qui est pas mal sans
être excellent c'est un peu décevant
quand on prend un spécialiste au tir
mais globalement quand on prend le le
contexte psychologique du joueur et le
mal-être qu'il a du côté de Michigan on
voit ça peut s'expliquer on peut on peut
penser que ce sont que c'est un
pourcentage qui va être aussi lié au
fait que le jour dans sa tête ça se
passe pas très bien cette année même
s'il y a du mieux et que voilà Evelyne
saison quand même très compliqué
avec avec les Wolverine je vous ai
rajouté un deuxième site aujourd'hui
alors je vais vous la non pas du tout ce
que je veux faire pas trop de couture ça
vous intéresse pas trop je pense je vous
ai mis ce site là
que j'utilise de plus en plus hop je
vais le mettre dans le si vous mettre
dans le chat
ici ici
faudra que je voulais attaque dans les
ressources
ce site-là qu'est-ce qui nous montre
tout simplement ça montre les chats de
charte donc ça montre la répartition des
tirs des joueurs et ça montre en gros
leur efficacité plus vous êtes dans le
rouge foncé plus vous êtes fort par
rapport à la moyenne NCIS peut-être dans
le bleu foncé plus vous êtes faible par
la parole à la moyenne si donc vous
pouvez chercher soit par équipe soit par
joueur soit par match
la saison et vous pouvez regarder soit
avec la chatte zone donc comme ça soit
avec la petite zone où ça vous montre
vraiment chaque petit compartiment
et ça vous dit voilà l'efficacité moi je
préfère avec la chaude zone surtout pour
montrer en live c'est plus explicite et
c'est plus facile à visualiser donc
calebioston il est ici une efficacité
globale à 51,6 % ce qui est moyen sans
être dramatique on voit que près du
panier
63,6 % je lui dis que c'était la moyenne
on est dans du blanc c'est marqué dans
la moyenne
il a pris que 33 tiers près du cirque 33
lei up d'accord pour vous donner un
ordre d'idée tout de suite si je vais
dans le 45 degrés à droite à trois
points 33-3 points dans cette dans cette
section là donc voilà ça vous montre
comment le joueur est très
comment dire est très orienté sur le tir
extérieur ce que nous disait déjà
Anthony a 2 ans ça a pas beaucoup évolué
on a un joueur qui prend deux fois plus
quasiment de trois points
au total que de tir près du prix près du
panier qu'on va être dans la zone in the
pain un petit peu autour
du panier donc ce qui va être les layeux
un peu long les petits flotteurs les
petits Runner avec un peu de toucher
40,6 % de réussite seulement
sur 32 tentatives ce qui est assez
faible vous avez la moyenne qui a 44 %
sur secteur là
c'est un jour qui est un peu en
difficulté à mi distance on voit qu'à
très très peu de tir 4 tirs de ce
côté-là c'est ici de fichier et 5 ici
nous voilà très peu de tir dans
l'entre-deux et peu d'efficacité
globalement on va être honnête
maintenant qu'on va regarder à trois
points si vous avez du bruit à côté de
vous inquiétez pas c'est juste un de mes
petits qui vient qui vient dire coucou
vous savez que j'ai peut-être si vous
connaissez maintenant que j'ai trois
chats donc ils viennent de temps en
temps faire un petit coucou au live
remplacer mon plus petit
il est 42e
big board du Big word on est d'accord
qu'il donnera pas si bah non comme tu es
comme je te le dis chaque semaine il
espionne ils vendent ils vendent du clic
donc ils le mettent 42e là parce que le
joueur a question début de saison mais
il va tester ça se trouve il va faire un
bon tournoi de pique-t-elle avec les
standards qu'il est en train de
d'imposer actuellement à plus d'une
dizaine de points avec avec des bons
pourcentages et d'un coup ils vont le
mettre au top 15 et
et voilà quoi c'est ça fera du plus près
de la du clic ils seront content donc il
devrait pas tomber aussi ce serait
surprenant en tout cas que ça arrive
donc on disait à trois points ce qui est
intéressant c'est que il prend beaucoup
de tir de tous les côtés il est pas
latéralisé gauche droite vous voyez
c'est tir ici 47 ici donc un peu plus de
tir de côté gauche 19 tir dans l'axe 33
à 45 droite et 17 dans le corner il est
globalement efficace partout
un peu en défaut dans l'axe mais avec un
volume assez faible c'est ça c'est les
tirs qui va beaucoup prendre en il va
faire du pick and pop pesant d'écran
majoritairement cette Carla dans l'axe
les tiers pris en pick-up poseur d'écran
les tirs dans les corner c'est soit les
tirs en transition soit ça va être les
tirs en sortie d'écran en sortie de
flopy donc les remontées depuis la ligne
de fond où il va tirer à trois points ça
c'est les tirs dans le corner et dans le
cadre pendant 45 degrés et dans les
corners c'est des tirs de fin de chaîne
alors pourquoi est-ce qu'un peu plus de
tir à gauche
tout simplement parce qu'il est droitier
notre ami calebiostan et donc quand
là-bas arrive depuis sa droite donc
quand il est côté gauche que la balle
arrive depuis sa droite la balle arrive
directement sur sa main droite ce qui
lui permettent d'armée plus vite de
dégainer plus vite et de d'avoir plus
d'efficacité voilà c'est pour ça que
vous avez un peu plus de surpris
côté gauche côté droit c'est parce que
il va remonter côté gauche il va
attraper et il va pouvoir dégainer
directement donc plus de système avec un
démarquage sur ce 45 degrés là que sur
le 45 degrés opposé voilà j'espère que
j'étais assez clair que je t'ai pas
perdu dans mes dans mes explications
comme ça et on va pouvoir maintenant
aller regarder du film pour pour se
faire un avis un avis plus global alors
vous avez vu peut-être dans le chat que
le bot envoie des messages un peu
automatique je lui ai j'ai attendu je
progresse je progresse je lui ai demandé
de me mettre des messages automatisés
toutes les 10 15 minutes donc voilà vous
avez des petits des petits messages
d'information si je puis dire
pour me permettre de fluidifier de
rester un maximum avec vous et de pas de
pas décrocher parce que je savais que
j'arrive pas à faire deux choses en même
temps tout simplement on va la regarder
du film donc le film je voulais préparer
en quatre parties comme d'habitude pour
ceux qui nous connaissent bien première
partie on va la regarder le tir
parce que c'est quand même ça qu'on
essaie de vendre avec Caleb Houston du
shoot on va regarder le tiers pris en
catch and shoot
en fin de chaîne le tiers pris en sortie
d'écran est-ce qu'il y a du tiers pris
en pull-up on a vu qu'il avait quasiment
pas mais je vais essayer de vous montrer
un peu un peu de un peu de simple de ça
un peu d'échantillons de ça excusez-moi
et après on va regarder un peu de tir
ouh là là demain je vais chez le
coiffeur donc vous aurez plus à
supporter cette mèche de cheveux là qui
parle n'importe comment c'est fini
demain j'y vais je vous le promets
et
puis voilà un peu le tiramis distance
aussi au lancer franc ensuite dans une
deuxième partie on regardera ce que le
jour peut faire ballon
ma droite ma gauche est-ce qu'il peut
changer de rythme est-ce que il est il a
un premier pas explosif ou pas est-ce
qu'il est capable d'aller au Cercle tout
ça
on regardera les ensuite en 3e mois le
packingham il y a très peu de clip mais
on va voir si le joueur peut initier du
jeu collectivement est-ce que ça passe
sur fonctionnel ou juste est-ce qu'il
vaut rien est-ce que c'est un trou noir
et enfin défensivement est-ce qu'il peut
encaisser du contact est-ce qu'il peut
tenir latéralement des profils
différents extérieurs et liés intérieur
est-ce qu'il peut switcher est-ce qu'il
a des une bonne compréhension du jeu ou
pas voilà c'est le programme un bon
efficace feel gold passante c'est
combien
alors en NCA
ensier on attend du 60 65 % ça devient
quand même assez intéressant voilà
c'est parce qu'on va avoir de
normalement des joueurs qui vont les
bons joueurs NCIS en tout cas qui sont
amenés à leur NBA
domine souvent physiquement et donc
des meilleurs pourcentages près du
panier donc c'est pour ça qu'une moyenne
Annecy et attente c'est vers 70 % près
du cercle donc forcément ça les monte ça
implique des lancer francs ce qui montre
le pourcentage global et après ça dépend
de ton stage à trois points aussi voilà
mais vers 65 % d'efficacité
en
FG ça devient vraiment intéressant donc
allez bisous je t'aime du coup n'est pas
trop là dedans parce qu'il a beaucoup
bonne année notamment près du cercle ce
qui baisse son
ce pourcentage on va aller du coup sur
le film on va commencer avec le tir
parce que c'est comme ça qui nous
intéresse avec ce joueur je laisse
tourner comme d'habitude au départ et
après on se fait ça
en clip par clip au ralenti si besoin
est voilà
alors vous inquiétez pas c'est pas c'est
pas votre live qui a planté c'est juste
mon PC qui met des fiches comme
d'habitude
c'est dramatique ah non il me l'a ouvert
en dessous superbe sa quel plaisir un
peu là
ok c'est pas grave c'est pas grave c'est
pas grave c'est pas grave
ok donc le tien je vous ai dit on va
regarder du catch and shoot beaucoup de
tiers pré-enquation shoot notamment
enfin quasiment que ça notamment en fin
de chaîne vous allez voir que chez ce
joueur et les mains sont prêtes
il se repositionne bien donc c'est à
dire qu'il suit bien le mouvement
collectif pour pour pouvoir se rendre
disponible l'armée est rapide main
gauche main droite on a pas beaucoup
besoin de beaucoup de
mouvement parasite pour se repositionner
on est capable de dégainer main gauche
une carte de dégainer main droite
vitesse
intéressante distance NBA on va très peu
avoir de tir où il va poser un dribble
et
il va enchaîner c'est assez rare c'est
pas non plus un jour qui va beaucoup
feinter une prise de tir pour pouvoir
ensuite déclencher à trois points
globalement qui a un défenseur ou pas il
s'en fout lui il poulabe sur ta face là
il va être plus en difficulté c'est
quand il va pas pouvoir rentrer dans le
ballon notamment sur les phases de
transition alors il aime beaucoup tirer
à 3 points en première attention être à
plus mon petit qui fait n'importe quoi
ça suffit bonhomme merci
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe donc
voilà je disais il va être il va avoir
besoin de vraiment rentrer dans sa balle
pour pouvoir tirer le geste est assez
fluide non il a vraiment très très beau
geste il est assez gainé sur son
déclenchement là tu y a pas trop de
souci ça va il va en début de saison il
y avait beaucoup d'hésitation il
rentrait rien il a fait des matchs 1 sur
7 à 1 / 8 et du coup il avait vraiment
beaucoup d'hésitation et est-ce que
enfin ce qui avait pour conséquence qui
m'était pas dedans il y avait beaucoup
plus de retard dans son tiers et plus la
saison elle avance et plus on retrouve
le Caleb du stade shooter en série et là
ça fait ficelle ce que je voulais vous
montrer alors vous allez voir qu'il y a
des
il y a des tirs
comment dire il y a des tirs qui ratent
ce qui m'intéresse donc quand il y aura
de s'étire c'est que je voulais vous
montrer que la mécanique change pas
c'est qu'il y a pas une mécanique qui
est régulière le tir il est assez
régulier et c'est juste vraiment une
question d'adresse puisque une question
de problème de geste lorsqu'il est chaud
simplement lorsqu'il va être en pull-up
là il va partir avec les jambes en avant
il va mettre les pieds en avant il va
casser son son corps et ça va provoquer
souvent des échecs il est le c'est
vraiment pour l'instant un joueur de
catch and shoot et c'est pas un mec qui
va déclencher of the wibble alors vous
allez voir aussi qu'il a qu'on l'utilise
parfois comme je disais tout à l'heure
comme poseur d'écran pick and pop alors
les écrans ne créent pas beaucoup de
décalage mais il offre du spaceing et
c'était peut-être un rôle qui pourrait
avoir NBA il fait 2 m 01 donc pourquoi
pas utiliser comme un poste poste 4 vous
savez que moi j'aime bien poste 3 post 4
et poser des écrans pouvoir ensuite se
démarquer et mettre des tirs comparer un
Baldwin junior par exemple dans le tir
alors ouais Baldwin junior
comment dire à un problème de rotation
dans le bassin on avait vu
ou le geste était en deux mouvements et
que il avait du mal à tourner le bassin
et ensuite déclencher par contre Baldwin
Junior a un tiers vraiment plus
intéressant dans le fait ou quand il est
face à toi pour déclencher par-dessus
toi par-dessus le défenseur voilà parce
que quand la buse tu en as plus de mal à
faire forcément vu que le joueur le
joueur est moins grand et que l'armée
part de moins haut que pas de baltring
voilà ça c'est pour le Global je les ai
laissé tourner vous voyez la séquence de
piscine pop on va revenir dessus ralenti
ça c'est quelque chose qu'on pourra
projeter du coup au niveau supérieur
donc on va regarder ça
rapidement rapidement à prendre son
temps mais regarder ça au ralenti on va
pas tous se les faire parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de
de films assez similaires
donc là enfin de chaîne Katch and should
dans le corner le geste rapide alors
c'est pas celui-là que je voulais que
par lequel je voulais commencer on va
commencer par du positif peut-être ce
sera plus sympa pour le joueur
on dit on voulait celui-là merci
donc voilà les mâles sont prêtes dans
l'axe le tiret rapide on voit que les
pieds sont
sont dans l'axe équilibré il y a pas de
souci là-dessus ça part bien là on est
ici on est dans le à gauche 45 degrés
encore une fois les mains sont prêtes
directement orientées vers le passeur
c'est vraiment un mec qui est qui a
appris à tirer à gros volume et ça fait
ficelle ici il sort de mouvement
j'attrape la réception et je déclenche
encore rapidement malgré le défenseur on
peut se regarder on a Brice mcgowens qui
lui revient dessus
il n'hésite pas
hop ma go one est sur lui c'est pas
grave pour lui il est gay il n'y a pas
de souci c'est vraiment un pyromane en
puissance là on est corner droit je
réceptionne et tout de suite je re
déclenche rapidement
encore une fois dans le corner côté
gauche on se remet les mâles sont prêtes
tout de suite
la balle elle arrive forcément droite
moins de tir et ça fait ficelle
donc là on va comme je vous disais on
remet ici au début j'ai raté pardon il
vient poser un écran pour un floppy
l'écran ne crée pas de décalage mais
tout de suite je me je suis prêt et je
vais déclencher voilà ça c'est quelque
chose qu'on pourrait attendre de lui au
niveau supérieur ce que Doug McDermott
commence à faire pas mal du côté des
sports actuellement placer un écran pop
coca dans les écrans voilà ce genre de
choses là
donc là en sortie de course il y a une
petite hésitation on peut quand même
tirer malgré qu'il y a un défense donc
vous voyez c'est un joueur qui est
capable après sortie de course de vite
récupérer
et comme je vous dis pas de dribble là
normalement on pourrait avoir un petit
dribble pour passer pour effacer le
Cloud out mais non ça c'est quelque
chose qui fait pas malheureusement
et ensuite
on redéclenche
alors j'ai vu deux petits commentaires
vite fait projeter comme un spécial du
tiroir NBA ouais je pense je pense que
c'est ce qu'on va attendre de qu'on va
attendre de lui parce qu'on va voir que
le dribble est vraiment pas là et que la
finition contact est vraiment pas bonne
non plus donc peut-être comme un
macdermott vraiment spécialiste du tir
sur le poste délier mécanique tellement
rapide merci pour ce que tu fais dur le
got c'est gentil de ta part merci à toi
le gode je ne sais pas je ne pense pas
derrière il y a bien mieux mais on
essaie de faire au mieux en tout cas
donc merci merci à toi genre uniquement
de système du coup
oui pour moi ça va pas être un créateur
individuel ça va pas être un mec qui va
être assez bon pour créer en sortie de
dribble donc ça va vraiment être un jour
de mouvement
donc là on voit encore une fois
transition il a pas peur il peut
dégainer
et ça va être un joueur qui va
je pense plus efficace dans une dans une
attaque qui bouge
plus tôt que juste le mettre dans un
corps ce sera un peu un peu du gâchis
autant le faire le faire sortir des
écrans et cetera parce que c'est quelque
chose où on voit qu'il peut briller
parce qu'il rééquilibre très vite voyez
très vite dans l'axe au niveau de son
corps et très équilibré et très gainé et
il déclenche très vite donc ce serait
quelque chose qui serait positif donc là
en sortie de end of
encore une fois
on peut revenir dessus mais donc il y a
une passe Dickinson sortie de NDH et
très vite me mets dans l'axe panier je
déclenche
et ça fait Filoche
donc ici pick and pop c'est ce qu'on
voyait tout à l'heure donc il y a un
double pose successif donc ça c'est
tellement hors pick and pop la défense
elle est focus sur Hunter de kinson qui
est la menace principale de l'équipe
donc on ressort pour qu'elle ait du
stade il y a un Cloud 2 notre ami renard
pour junior
et lui il s'en fout il déclenche et on
voit encore une fois au niveau de la
distance
pour revenir dessus
on a une distance NBA largement NBA
donc ici voilà les mâles sont prêtes
celui-là ne rentre pas comme je vous
disais ce qui m'intéresse c'est de
regarder au niveau de la mécanique du
tir on a pas de différence sur un tiré
par rapport entre un tir à tes amis vous
voyez que là le tir c'est la même chose
et puis ils sont équilibrés aussi le
corps aussi donc voilà quand il rate
c'est un problème d'adresse c'est pas un
problème de technicité il y a le joueur
est très régulier dans son corps et ça
c'est vraiment intéressant donc ici
sortie d'écran il y a une remontée dans
l'axe et on voit pareil le tien ne
rentrera pas mais c'est pas un problème
de
de régularité physique mais je t'en prie
d'adresse par contre je crois que c'est
sur celui-là voilà encore une sortie
d'écran il y a un floppy je me recadre
dans l'axe et là le pied par un peu en
avant mais c'est vraiment vraiment très
très léger
encore une sortie d'écran de dans un
système de flopy je me repousse à 12
distance cette fois-ci vous voyez que là
le tiers par largement en avant pour le
coup cette fois-ci et du coup ça rentre
pas une bonne défense de stage Stéphane
ovitch
et qu'est-ce qui fait que ça rentrera
pas on a vu au lancer franc nous vous la
voyez quand je vous dis que le joueur il
a il a des pannes d'adresse au début de
saison il était à 2 sur 9 il y a
beaucoup de matchs que vous pouvez voir
à 3h10 4 sur 14 et cetera vraiment des
grosses des grosses soirées en panne
d'adresse des 1 sur 8 en début de saison
ou tu te dis ouf et là il remonte il
remonte doucement la pente
au lancer franc moi j'ai pas de problème
au niveau de l'armée au niveau du de la
gestuelle et cetera après je suis pas un
spécialiste on va être honnête non plus
mais j'ai pas quelque chose qui me qui
me choque
et nos concours là et cette fois-ci je
voulais vous montrer un petit prix à
distance à trois points 4G de très très
loin quoi
quand on parle de Deep tree
là on y est on est sur le logo de
Michigan quasiment
sans aucune hésitation voilà
et je pense qu'on a à peu près fait le
tour faut mettre c'est autre chose ou
pas
on a fait le tour c'est le c'est le
système qu'on a vu tout à l'heure on
voit que les mains elles vont s'orienter
voilà ça j'aime bien hop je suis à une
pause dessus mais moi elles sont
orientées
sur la base pour pouvoir déclencher
ensuite très rapidement
voilà donc dans le dans les types de tir
parce qu'on aime bien quand même parler
de type de tirs ça qui nous intéresse
pour récapituler
joueur de fin de fin de chaîne joueur de
système en sortie d'écran dans des des
sorties de curl sans sortie de flopy
soit voilà sortie de on fait la screen
fait screen comme vous voulez et joueur
de où là je vais aller Condor genre de
pick-up à terme donc pose d'écran et
ensuite donne des 11 par exemple ou pose
d'écran et je vais créer un décalage et
je peux Filoche à trois points donc
plusieurs types de tir mais pas de tir
prix en sortie de drip pas de tiers prix
derrière l'écran sur un pic and roll la
défense elle passe en dessous je fais la
page je veux dire c'est pas quelque
chose c'est pas un répertoire dans
lequel on attend qu'elle a besoin au
niveau supérieur maintenant on va aller
sur le sur le drive
alors hop j'ai appelé ça de RIB ici
et on va pouvoir lancer alors
belle mécanique j'estre rapide
trajectoire bien haut s'il tombe pas
Opel zonix et il se fera une place le
petit tacle gratuit alors je t'avoue que
j'aimerais vu les problèmes
psychologiques du joueur et comment il a
du mal à se mettre en rythme j'aimerais
bien qu'il tombe pas onyx qui sont les
spécialistes pour pour tuer des pour
tuer des jeunes talents pour tuer des
des Rocky des contrats rougis donc
j'aimerais bien qu'ils ne tombe pas onyx
et Opel écoute ils ont eu un peu
difficile pendant quelques années en
spécialiste du tir maintenant je pense
pas qu'il y a une place particulièrement
pour
pour ce jour-là pas au Kiss non plus
alors j'ai vu ta question à Swingy avec
ou sans dire on va
on va attendre
on va attendre le la playlist défense
pour voir ça j'ai pas te spoiler tout
programme non plus pas au Kings non plus
pas au Kings non plus
les Kings ils ont besoin de trois points
non non t'excuse pas t'excuse pas et pas
de souci t'inquiète c'est pas c'est pas
une dictature c'est juste que je
t'explique mon programme mais t'en fais
pas les kids ont besoin de trois ponts
et de défense
mais ils vont sûrement drafté assez haut
et donc j'espère pour eux qui pourraient
avoir mieux que Call of Houston nous
propose maintenant si j'arrive à avoir
un pic entre la 15e et la troisième
place pourquoi pas pourquoi pas il
répond à un besoin d'un côté au moins
ah mais on tombe d'environnement écoute
je vais je vais j'ai envie de croire je
suis en positif j'ai envie de croire
dans le nouvel environnement de King là
il y a des joueurs un peu sérieux
pourquoi pas aller du coup dans le Drive
vous allez voir que le joueur alors au
début je vous ai mis les côtés un peu
sympa je vous fais croire je vous fais
croire que que mec peut mettre des
eurostape et tout donc en transition on
voit qu'il est à l'aise c'est un joueur
qui a montré qu'il était capable de
finir dès demain
main droite main gauche mais c'est une
dominante au niveau de la main droite
c'est un jour qui va très très peu au
Cercle pourquoi parce que c'est pas un
athlète tout simplement c'est pas la
tête de niveau NBA le premier pas
explosif c'est ce que vous allez voir
plusieurs fois
la c'est pas une menace verticale de
très haute qualité c'est à dire qu'il va
il a pas la tête au Cercle c'est pas un
jour qu'on va retrouver au concours de
dunk il a plus souvent finir avec un
layote qu'autre chose c'est un joueur
qui a toujours du mal à absorber le
contact et ça se voit des deux côtés du
terrain c'était un problème qui était
déjà souligné il y a 2 ans par Antoine
lorsqu'il était au U16 prime qu'on a
retrouvé
U19 et qui se confirme du côté de
Michigan c'est un joueur
qui voilà qui a du mal à prendre le
dessus genre c'est défenseurs directs et
je reçois toujours les pivots même les
pivots NCIS même si je dans une
conférence où il y a quand même des gros
pivots dans la Big tn mais voilà il va
prendre le dessus sur les pivot NCIS
donc il va être plus dans l'évitement
donc on va très souvent avoir des
tentatives de l'hélioc qui font qui font
gamelles ou qui font brick ou qui se
rencontrer donc voilà quand il part en
drive
le on a un drive qu'on appelle parce que
j'appelle uniforme c'est-à-dire que il
va pas changer de nom pendant son drive
il va pas passer de la main droite à la
main gauche il y a très peu de
variations de rythme donc il va pas
accélérer pendant son drive il va pas
décélérer pendant son drive ce qu'il le
rend assez prévisible il va pas non plus
varier la longueur de son dribble il va
pas d'un coup avoir un dribble long il
va pas non plus avoir un dribble plus
bas et varier la hauteur de son dribble
voilà c'est vraiment très uniforme et il
va compter
très souvent sur le fait que déjà un
décalage et que lui n'est plus que femme
n'est plus besoin que de finir notamment
du côté de Michigan sur des sorties de
curl doit y avoir un système qui va le
démarquer dans le au panier et il va
récupérer le ballon en sortie de curl et
sur un de dribble il va pouvoir aller
finir au Cercle voilà tout simplement ce
qu'on va ce qu'on va pouvoir observer je
vous ai mis quelques clips aussi lignes
de fond parce que c'est un jour qui
utilise très souvent la ligne de fond
donc lorsqu'on le met sur le corner
majoritairement
parlant les joueurs vont soit repasser
pour revenir à 45 degrés pour un
coéquipier soit ils vont essayer
d'attaquer sur un drive en prenant
l'extérieur lui il aime beaucoup driver
ligne de fond et de là soit et finir
soit passer à un joueur qui va couper
dans l'axe c'est un des rares qu'il le
fait autant il le fait
avec une efficacité moyenne je pense
qu'il y a une habitude qui a été prise
donc vous allez le voir alors là ici
forcément il prend l'extérieur pour me
contredire mais c'est une petite qui a
été prise je suis pas sûr qu'à terme ce
soit vraiment une arme si intéressante
que ça on va peut-être falloir
leur corriger nos il va surprendre les
défenses je pense au début par ce drive
là qui est pas quelque chose de
classique en NBA mais attends ça devrait
pas être une
une
arme très efficace parce que assez
facile à défendre tant tu peux enfermer
l'attaquant sur cette ligne sur cette
ligne de fond avec peu d'espace voilà
on commence c'est le premier clip donc
ça tombe bien
avec de la transition donc qui va se
projeter rapidement vers l'avant on va
voir un petit euro step c'est pas un
mouvement qui maîtrise particulièrement
sur de la transition très souvent on
voit des joueurs qui brillaient donc là
il feinte pardon l'euro step justement
sur le pied gauche et il part pied droit
ne vous laissez pas avoir par ses
highlight là
on va vous vendre sur Youtube la recette
facile il y a un beau move avec une
belle comment dire une belle
prise d'avance et un vrai quart de de
fait de vous laisser pas avoir par des
lettres comme ça en transition la
plupart des joueurs qui arriveront NBA
sont capables de faire ça donc voilà le
dribble ligne de fond on est ici belle
protection de balle qu'on regarde par
rapport au pivot c'est pas un joueur qui
rentre en contact on l'a dit donc
une fois que je suis en l'air là je vais
changer ma direction ici j'évite le
contact et je vais finir mais c'est pas
genre qui va rentrer dedans c'est pas
gentil qui va essayer de monter
par-dessus
là on l'a encore en ligne de fond
donc voilà le par contre ce que j'aime
bien c'est son jeu d'appui voyez on va
remettre dessus il va feinter plusieurs
prises de direction il va faire soit le
4 ligne de fond est terminée au Cercle
soit il va fêter revenir sur le N9 donc
là on regarde ici je fais je fais un
double-face le défense censé prendre
dedans pitchenrol et je vais partir
drive main gauche et comme je vous ai
dit finir main gauche donc là on se
protège de coffeekband qui est un pivot
massif qui pourrait avoir une pige en
NBA un gros pivot et on va finir de la
main gauche
ici je suis ma droite sur une sortie de
eldorf et on va aller voir
drive main droite et je vais aller
jusqu'au cercle voyez il y a pas
d'accélération
il y a pas non plus de
premier explosif et je me fais rattraper
par Zaki dit le pivot passif canadien
donc son compatriote est coéquipier U19
voilà qui dit est déjà revenu dessus et
derrière j'ai pas la capacité athlétique
et la technicité pour pouvoir finir fort
au sein
ici les mains sont prêtes pour un 4chan
de foot je décide de partir en drive
main droite
et j'essaie avec un flotteur de faire un
écart donc un petit peu touché sur ce
secteur là c'est pas non plus une arme
qu'on retrouve très souvent et on
l'avait vu dans les statistiques 40 %
seulement j'en sais tentative ce qui est
assez faible et là pareil un drive trop
uniforme je me fais rattraper par Max
Christie et j'ai pas la capacité à aller
finir au contact
bah à la main départ main gauche
je pars le ballon il y a une mauvaise
lecture de jeu
je suis pas explosif donc je fais pas la
différence en mode défenseur direct je
vois pas l'aide qui va venir ici dans
l'axe là je frise stop il va pas l'aide
il aurait pu
cliquer ici pour Élie Brooks
il le voit pas et du coup ça provoque
une perte de balle voilà
mais je pense que vous l'avez compris
c'est pas un joueur qu'on va voir
exister balle en main il va pouvoir
essayer de finir sur des démarquage mais
c'est qualitat athlétiques sont pas
assez
assez bonnes pour pouvoir non plus être
un vrai joueur de cut donc à l'image
d'un doute Mac Dermot encore une fois
il devrait avoir un jeu assez en
périphérie et doux mcdermot tu étais
déjà bien plus développé physiquement et
meilleur Finistère au niveau une sieste
donc c'est peut-être peut-être un
objectif à visé à terme pour ce joueur
et peut-être pas avant peut-être pas du
rêve on vous parle de Doom McDermott
mais c'est un mec qui a déjà eu trois
contrats NBA qui est là depuis
maintenant 8 ans donc ce sera déjà pas
si mal voilà
oui ce serait parfait pour lui alors
il nous reste souvent maintenant les
shooters qui bougent bien et tout et qui
ont des problèmes un peu athlétiques on
les trouve bien au lit des fois je dis
non ça marche pas genre Patrick
baldwinner non ça marche pas pour lui
autant qu'elle est juste un Wii
typiquement c'est un joueur
qui pourrait se régaler au hits pardon
excusez-moi et qui a le shoot le style
et cetera qui
qui vit très parfaitement dans un
effectif de notre ami Éric polstraat hop
là donc on va aller maintenant sur la 3e
partie sur la passe est-ce que le joueur
est au moins passe en fonctionnel on a
vu que c'était pas un créateur ballon
main c'était pas un slash c'était pas un
finisseur près du panier mais est-ce
qu'il est capable au moins de renverser
le jeu de profiter d'un surnombre
exetera pour pour se rendre utile ou non
on va voir aussi quelques séquences il
arrive à trouver la passe décisive et on
va pouvoir revenir là-dessus tout
simplement on est parti
alors la passe
alors qu'est-ce qu'on va dans ces clips
là on va voir des différents types de
passes on va voir que le joueur il est
capable en ce qui drive de retrouver
rapidement un joueur ouvert donc c'est
un passeur qu'on va qualifier de
fonctionnel la balle elle stagne pas
dans ses dans ses mains quand je vous
disais driving de fond il est très
friand de ça driver lignes de fond et
fournir le ballon un joueur qui
couperait dans l'axe quelque chose qui
l'aime bien faire maintenant c'est assez
prévisible et parfois il y a des il y a
des pertes de balles un peu stupide
comme je vous dis la balle elle reste
pas dans ses mains donc très rapidement
va trouver un shooter par contre
quand je vais jouer sur du pick and roll
les passes elles sont pas du tout bien
timé il est pas à l'aise avec la passe
au sol il est pas à l'aise avec la passe
lobée
dès qu'on est sur sa main gauche pour
lui ça devient très très compliqué de
passer donc on va passer à demain et dès
que son axe donc vision panier
globalement n'exception de vision il
voit pas le jeu donc voilà pasteur
fonctionnel oui mais vous allez très
vite comprendre que c'est pas un
créateur collectif
donc voilà on va regarder ça maintenant
ou ralenti donc on va commencer on va
commencer avec cette passe là donc là
vous l'avez dans l'axe et très vite hop
je décale pour le joueur ouvert et je
casse la défense et il le fait très bien
là-dessus il y a pas de souci c'est pas
un gros cœur c'est un joueur qui qui
réagit rapidement offensivement donc
voilà pick and roll voyez pas ce sol le
timing est pas bon la passe elle arrive
trop basse trop loin par rapport à la
prise de position poste bas que veut
interdit kinson qui du coup doit
derrière
dégainer rapidement parce qu'il lui pose
problème là je vous ai dit que dans
l'axe ligne de fond donc pour tous fait
avoir voyez que la défense
redescend fortement sur le joueur
interdit kinson même si il tire à 3
points un petit peu il est pas très
respecté donc toute la défense elle
tombe et là il arrive à cliquer pour le
pivot là bas ça arrive plutôt dans le
comment dire dans la main de son joueur
donc c'est pas trop mal exécuté
quelque chose qu'il aime bien ici c'est
pareil on est sur du drive dans son
champ de vision et je peux transmettre
derrière donc assez c'est un mec qui
devrait
fluidifie une attaque et là on est
revenu sur l'axe
à la base de relax voilà quelque chose
qu'il aime beaucoup faire et en
transition tout simplement devant lui
même s'il est encore un peu de temps la
trouver cette passe au sol
et là pour finir la passe dans l'axe
alors un petit peu de manipulation
visuelle ici
manipulation visuelle c'est-à-dire que
je ne regarde pas l'endroit où je passe
la balle pour
déconcentrer la défense voilà là il
vient transmettre dans l'axe pour Moussa
Diabaté sans regarder il y a une bonne
défense derrière voilà
je peux m'éterniser sur un secteur
où il y a pas de toute façon c'était
juste pour vous c'est toujours rester en
pain compartiment pas compartiment
passe en fonctionnel passeur d'équipe
par un créateur individuel pas un
créateur collectif encore une fois
confirme notre impression que le joueur
est un joueur de rotation un rôle player
accès sur le tir extérieur maintenant
nous demander tout à l'heure est-ce que
c'est un sweet Andy avec ou sans dit
est-ce que c'est un soulier où est-ce
que c'est un souilland
globalement
c'est un soutien
je vais pas vous vous sur votre projet
mais ne partez pas ne quittez pas tout
de suite le problème de galette il y en
a deux en fait premièrement latéralement
il est pas capable de tenir latéralement
des extérieurs et il se fait tout le
temps prendre par les premiers pas à
s'explosif des arrières donc là vous
avez un exemple Jason IV ça arrive à des
gens bien mais il va se faire prendre
sur les sur les premiers pas notamment
quand il va faire un clarosoft derrière
s'il y a une fente et une accélération
il est battu et le sa deuxième
difficulté
mon live en attaque au niveau du contact
ça se retrouve en défense il encastreet
mal le contact donc dès que vous mettez
de l'impact sur ce sur ce sur ce joueur
en défense et que vous lui rentrez un
peu dedans et recule et du coup ensuite
vous avez un
un accès au cercle qui est tout tracé
qui est offert donc voilà il est pas
comment dire
il montre des signes de
motivation en défense vous voyez là
encore une fois des fois si mon il
essaie de tenir latéralement essaie de
lutter dans l'écran il essaie de de
rester
devant son attaquant mais il se prend un
coup il recule et derrière vous avez
vous avez une finition facile donc
va falloir mettre de la masse chez ce
joueur s'il veut espérer pouvoir
défendre en
NBA globalement on va souvent essayer de
le placer sur le moins bon Eli adverse
et on va le placer sur un ailier qui
porte pas le ballon on va essayer de le
faire défendre sur les sur les écrans
et il va falloir qu'il apprenne le
système défensif au début d'année il
était perdu les
coéquipiers le repousser jean-luce dans
le dos lui indiquer qu'il devait prendre
parce qu'il savait pas qu'il devait
prendre dans le système il savait pas
qu'on switcher il savait pas quand
est-ce qu'il devait venir en rotation
côté faible côté fort et tout donc il
s'est fait très critiquer là-dessus moi
je trouve que ça se voit un peu moins
maintenant du côté de Migennes il a
compris le système de jeu donc il va
falloir qu'il s'adapte en NBA que ça
prendra peut-être un petit peu de temps
mais à terme devrait être à défenseur
correct sur les choix les Élim par
contre il prendra jamais le meilleur
attaquant poste de poste 3 postes 4
porteur de baladeur elle a trop pas
assez rapide pour les extérieurs pas
assez puissant pour les ailiers
il oriente latéralement il s'arrête très
limité voilà j'espère que j'ai répondu à
vos interrogations
secteur là du jeu du joueur je suis bien
conscient qu'on que je comprends pas un
phénomène
je vois pas du rêve avec ce gars-là dans
ma projection
moi je l'ai mis 26e sur une fin de
premier tour pourquoi parce que je pense
que ça peut être un joueur ouais c'est
un massacre non pas un massacre mais
c'est pas c'est pas voilà c'est pas
hyper restant mais globalement c'est un
jour de fin de premier tour début de
second tour voilà c'est un joueur qui va
de vous donner du spacing là vous avez
mon petit qui vous dit bonjour tu dis
coucou fois que tu casses les burnes
depuis tout à l'heure pour avoir
l'intention tu peux dire bonjour au chat
ah il y a la crevette voilà ça c'est la
crevette numéro 3
qui me fait la misère et qui veut de la
tension pendant que j'aimais mon plus
grand qui vient aussi à côté
excusez-moi pour cette parenthèse cette
parenthèse de ça ah salut Megane ça fait
très plaisir de t'avoir coucou ça me
fait hyper plaisir de t'avoir ce soir
avec moi j'espère que tu vas bien je
suis hyper content que tu as retrouvé
ton petit bout donc je te fais de gros
bisous
et puis je suis très très content je
suis soulagé surtout voilà excusez-moi
donc voilà c'est
elle est trop bien ma voix
c'est gentil c'est gentil
tu es intéressant quand même oui voilà
c'est un jour qui est intéressant dans
le dans son offens qui bouge vraiment
bien qui est capable d'écarter le jeu
qui est capable d'exister je vous ai dit
sur des sorties d'écran qui est capable
de poser des écrans qui est capable
de venir bien dans l'axe coupé proposer
une solution et de et de transmettre
rapidement le ballon
donc c'est un joueur qui va être sur une
fin de premier tour dans une équipe qui
est déjà bien bâtie qui va chercher un
spécialiste pouvoir avoir un contrat on
pense en 25 26 27 28 29 30
Milwaukee j'en parle souvent
Brooklyn qui va vouloir avoir du
spaceing Denver un jour qui peut
s'éclater du côté des nuggets avec
beaucoup de jeux de floppy de démarquage
de cut avec kitch et des end of et tout
ça ça pourrait être super bien de ce
côté-là les Lakers on aurait peut-être
terriblement besoin pour apporter un peu
de un peu de tir
c'est pas un joueur qui voilà je vois
c'est pas c'est un joueur qui ont une
crème qui sera pas probablement pas All
Star visée dogm McDermott voilà le
potentiel de McDermott ce serait
vraiment déjà très très bien donc avoir
deux contrats NBA c'est vraiment bien
pour une fin de premier tour même un
second tour maintenant la question c'est
savoir est-ce qu'il y a mieux ou pas
dans le sur le même profil dans le dans
le même spot vous avez vous allez avoir
des joueurs plus expérimentés
3 4 ans avec des corps plus près et qui
pourraient te défendre plus efficacement
ça dégradé système je pense ici
Agadir s'il tombe je pense ici à Johnny
dusing même si c'est pas un défenseur
mais qui a encore prêt et qui aura un
peu plus de tir je pense ici faudrait
que j'aille regarder sur le bordel je
vais faire ça en même temps Hop qui
est-ce que je peux vous vendre au même
spot que lui qui va être à la bagarre
Bénédicte Mathurin son compère canadien
même si beaucoup de gens croient au
potentiel de Bénédicte naturel moi
beaucoup moins donc ils vont être à peu
près au même place qui vient de Murray
qui est un joueur déjà pour moi
plus expérimenté et qui pourra peut-être
faire plus de choses sur un terrain
maturins sera plus haut moi j'ai à peu
près dans le même spot donc je l'ai un
peu plus haut Bénédicte Mathurin mais il
y a pas un grand écart parce que je ne
crois pas comme je te l'avais dit enlève
la dernière fois on avait fait un live
dessus je crois pas au potentiel Ball en
moins si vous avez pas vu le replay il
est disponible sur notre chaîne YouTube
mais moi je crois pas dans le potentiel
de bélite Mathurin comme ça Massac parce
qu'il aimait du sien et oui puis
défensif quand même et malgré ça six
sort dans les corner avec le pied voilà
très bien très bien relais avec Mike
stable Dany green de bien ça risque
voilà un mec pour remplacer peut-être un
jour qui pourrait partir à furent Corma
un mec qui va sortir du banc qui va
apporter du spacing qui va avoir un peu
passé parce qu'il est jeune qui va
pouvoir bouger et cetera et et améliorer
et améliorer le spectacle de l'équipe
qui est-ce qu'on a dans le dans le même
rien que à peu près
voilà on a Wendel Moore si on regarde le
le board mais ici en même temps si vous
voulez suivre avec moi
hop là donc Wendel Moore à peu près à la
même place moi je préfère Wendel Moore
par exemple qui est le lait de Duke
suit Andy beaucoup plus athlétique
beaucoup plus près défensivement avec
plus de toucher Brice McGowan bah voilà
alors bref ma Gohan du coup je veux bien
avoir la discussion moi je prends Caleb
je t'aime devant bref ma Gwen parce que
ma Gwen et beaucoup plus fin ma Gohan
a pas encore le tir à la qualité de
cirque Stan et je crois pas non plus que
que ma Gohan pourrait finir près du
panier efficacement donc moi je le
prends devant ma Gwen je viens de le
dire beaucoup de soleil je l'ai je l'ai
je l'ai je l'ai je l'ai
est-ce que mon Top 40 là donc voyez je
l'ai même pas dans mon Top 40 et je peux
vous dire ça dans mon board où est-ce
qu'il est froid que j'ouvre ça mais
alors notre ami Brice je l'ai je l'ai
Coloco et là OK
je l'ai 47 donc je l'ai devant par
exemple je les verrai vous voyez je l'ai
devant Gaby point dit de
Michigan State par exemple qui a un
problème là-dedans latéralité aussi et
qui a beaucoup moins potentiel je l'ai
devant Justin Lewis le scorer de Market
qui pour le coup lui trop partir
l'attaque et qui est 3000 distance mais
je vais la voir je vais l'avoir devoirs
et Sony Graham dans lequel je crois pas
pour le potentiel offensif même si le
potentiel défensif est beaucoup plus
intéressant sauf qu'une grande pour
mettre sur un terrain de basket
actuellement vu que il sait pas attaqué
en tout cas il sait pas il se passe
faire il passe bien mais comme il aura
pas le ballon mais qu'il s'est pas
déblai je vais pas lui donner enfin je
vais pas pouvoir m'en servir en attaque
voilà
enfin voilà
Mours sous côté oui pour moi wendelours
côté si on parle bien de Wendel moi pas
Justin Moore et il y a deux mots les
deux je les ai devant mais enfin non
justement je l'appelle derrière mais
Wendel Moore les lieux de Duke qu'on a
ici si vous vous rappelez bien si vous
étiez là au premier live c'était notre
tout premier live sur twitch on parlait
de wendelbour donc 1m98 210 cm
d'envergure 96 kg qui est junior qui
était très très très très très coté
son arrivée à Juke et qui avait fait une
très mauvaise première saison et
deuxième saison avec un manque de cul
basket on se dit ouh là là c'était quoi
ce ce poulet sans tête et qui cette
année
en famille du plomb dans sa tête a
vraiment pris en maturité
et le leader de ces bouts de villes même
si bonne quero est la star leader c'est
Wendel Moore et vous voyez alors je vous
voyais non parce que j'ai pas mis à
piscine
normalement ça va paraître chez vous
aussi ouais voilà vous voyez ma dans
cette année wendelmour c'est 56 % au tir
40 % à 3 points 75 % on lance les Francs
et qui contribue au rebond qui prend de
la passe aussi qui intercepte
tu fais deux fois plus de passe que de
décisive que de ballon perdu donc
23 ans dans le big boss pour moi ça joue
très sous le côté
notre ami Wendel Moore et je pense que
partout il ira ce sera une bonne pioche
voilà
bon ben écoutez on a fait on a fait un
bon live un bon live à cap sur mes Caleb
du stade si vous croyez au joueur bah
tant mieux si vous ne le connaissiez pas
j'espère que vous avez pas trop dégoûté
non plus parce que
parce que bon le joueur même si déçoit
par rapport à ce qu'on attendait il
reste assez intéressant
dans un certain rôle de spécialiste et
puis on va pouvoir terminer par un petit
jeu si vous voulez qu'est-ce que est-ce
que vous avez une idée dans le chat
est-ce qu'il y a un truc que vous voulez
tester un petit quiz ou je ne sais
dites-moi dites-moi donc sinon je trouve
une idée vite fait rapidement et au
conclure là-dessus
rien à voir mais mon avis sur le nouveau
trailer de Pokémon
bah écoute comme tu sais gros joueur de
un vétérin de Pokémon si je peux avoir
compétitif mais gros joueur de Pokémon
très intrigué par cette 9e génération
qui arrive très très vite
à peine 2 ans après la 8g donc j'espère
que le jeu sera de qualité et j'ai vu
qu'il y avait un starter qui était un
chat en plante donc écoute très IP et
restant ne pas être déçu c'était pour la
parenthèse parenthèse Pokémon mais voilà
d'ailleurs Arceus ça a été bouclé là
c'est fini on est à plus de 60 heures de
jeu il y a il y a un petit peu de cul ce
baron shiny qui est tombé à quelques
jours je t'avoue je suis refait voilà
encore un live de qualité merci c'est
gentil de ta part j'espère que c'était
que c'est effectivement le cas on a
essayé de préparer un truc sympa un peu
bonus là on Lundi soir j'ai j'ai ma
chérie tendre qui n'était pas là ce soir
je me suis dit bon allez je vais faire
je vais faire un petit live parce que je
manquais de compagnie malgré malgré mes
trois petits
gros taf de Kate et merci pour le
partage bah merci à toi merci à toi
d'avoir regardé et très content que ça
t'ait plu ben écoutez on va on va faire
un petit aller on va faire un petit jour
essayer de se trouver un truc que je
vous propose on va prendre une équipe
NBA et on va essayer de trouver la la
fac de tous les jours de cette équipe
NBA vous me dites dans le chat une
équipe et on va essayer de se faire ça
alors
je vous avoue qu'il y a moins de choses
assez désastreux surtout sur les sur si
on a une équipe avec des vieux joueurs
j'ai rien compris mais c'était ma mère
c'est à toi ma belle ça m'a fait plaisir
de t'avoir avec nous c'est gentil de ta
part merci merci
écoute repose-toi bien bon courage pour
ta reprise profite bien de ton petit et
je vais et respire un coup je pense que
tu vas tu vas pouvoir dormir tranquille
cette nuit donc des gros bisous à tout
bientôt
voilà dites-moi dans les yeux d'une
équipe NBA et on va essayer de se
trouver
on va essayer de se trouver les facs de
tous les jours
à moins que j'ai plus personne dans le
Charlotte allez Charlotte les renettes
c'est pas mal les honnête c'est pas mal
donc on va essayer de se faire ça je
vais essayer de regarder ici
alors Charlotte Hornet faut pas que je
me fasse polluer un
roster donc
j'essaye au maximum ah bah regarder on
va faire comme ça
surtout que s'il en manque vous me direz
hop on va faire ça hop hop
normalement Charlotte ça devrait le
faire parce que parce qu'il y a beaucoup
de jeunes joueurs donc je pense que je
peux faire un truc pas trop mal sur
Charlotte est-ce que ça c'est gros pour
vous est-ce que je peux zoomer je peux
zoomer à en plus je vois qu'il y a un
spoil un peu en dessous donc je zoom et
comme ça on peut on peut être parti
alors comment est-ce qu'on fait ça je
vais mettre la liste des joueurs et on
va je vais on va alors je vais mettre
liste des jours donc je vais faire quoi
je vais faire
comment je vais faire bah écoutez je
vais j'essaie de les faire à l'oral vous
essayez de votre côté aussi dans votre
tête et
à la fin on corrige on essaie de voir le
nombre de points qu'on trouve donc je
l'ai fait un par un je vérifie à chaque
fois et on vérifie le nombre de points
sur le total ok donc la mets le ballon
donc la mets le bol il est pas les
sportif 3 2 1 Go il est pas parti à la
fac il a fait sa première année avant la
nuit en NBA du côté de villawara de
ilawara Hawks donc on vérifiera après
match bridgees Michigan State Kelly
Aubrey kenzas théozières Louisville
cordonnée Ward Butler alors c'était 5
par 5 pour pouvoir
le pouvoir alors la mets le ball la
méloball la melobo la ménopause
normalement il la voir à Hawks ah bah
c'est écrit là il la voir à Hawks c'est
bon c'est validé mal pris
tout tout qu'est-ce que j'ai autre chose
est-ce que j'ai un truc ici
université état du Michigan alors oui
mais
moi je veux le Miss chicken state
ils vont pas me dire vraiment son sac là
alors je sais parce que c'est mon jour
préféré ça du jour préféré donc c'est un
peu chiant quand même est-ce que je peux
l'avoir
ouais c'est la traduction et ça dégoûte
voilà Spartan de Michigan State c'est
bon ensuite on avait dit que c'était
Kelly ou break Kansas alors qu'il y
aurait
un terrible on avait dit Louisville donc
on va pouvoir vérifier hop hop hop hop
hop
ça va être là
Terry Rosières voilà
Louise c'est bon
ensuite tu es libre
Kenza normalement c'est bon coordonnées
World Butler
à l'époque où Butler est encore dans la
conférence horizon
avec coach
j'ai oublié le nom de son coach le JM
actuel des Celtics là j'ai un trou
pratique Steven voilà les bouledogs de
Butler c'est bon
mais ça ne pleure mais ça ne pleut me
lit je dirais
je dirais donc mais je ne suis pas sûr
belle saison de Scary Terry devient
Titus très correct ouais moi j'espère
que Thierry Rosa va se faire transférer
à terme pour essayer d'avoir un poste de
un peu plus grand et meilleur
défensivement encore pour pouvoir
comment dire planquer la meloball mais
c'est un joueur que je n'attendais pas à
ce niveau-là
et qui dépasse toutes mes espérances en
lui donc effectivement ça devient un
vrai titulaire intéressant mais je pense
qu'à terme il devrait il devrait être un
très bon 6e homme
j'espère que que leoness trouveront
trouveront en arrière de plus haute
qualité James booknight you can alors
voilà pourquoi pas James booknight même
si moi je ne crois pas énormément dans
ce joueur mon trésorel ce sera
Louisville
Washington ce sera Kentucky et le
dernier Cody Martin ce sera
N6 Tate dans n'importe quoi nevador
alors on va mais ça ne publie j'avais
dit Duke
on le voit ici Duke c'est bon James
booknight you come est-ce qu'il me la
note ici
et c'est pas la classe ça promet rien
que vous trouvez
envergure.co ça monsieur madame c'est le
symbole de la réussite
alors James booknight on va vérifier hop
hop Yukon c'est bon
on 13 arrêt Louisville est-ce que je
l'ai quelques pendant le coin oui
cardinal de Louisville c'est bon pitch
Washington Ken qui on le voit ici
Kentucky c'est bon Cody Martin Nevada
Nevada ici c'est bon ok on continue
alors on a qui
jetis sort de 10 ans c'est auburn
liquide charge alors on va dire que j'ai
pas vu le maillot mais c'est Kentucky
Kai Jones c'est Texas Scotty Lewis c'est
Florida
arnoldas cubota il joue vraiment
où en est
celui-là est-ce que Arnaud des CUB Volca
est vraiment un mec de Hornets parce que
si c'est le cas je n'ai absolument
aucune idée de la fac qui l'a fait donc
dites-moi dans le chat pour voir
à quel point je suis dans la sauce Jalal
Mac Daniel's Janet Daniel's alors
attends tu as fait un truc style Youn
Elvis you tape tu as fait un truc en
Anagram en 4 lettres merde
c'est le fils du gardien de la salle bon
bah c'est bon alors non mais je vais
voir qui tu es parce que je ne te
connais pas tu dois être lituanien vu le
nom donc on a DJ qui sort au burn
au burn c'est bon on voit le maillot ici
il est tout et qui volcan il a jamais
joué je crois ok à toi et ça compte dans
l'effectif Nick Richard donc elle te
quitte avant il y avait 20 ans de Carry
qui venait lui de Juke Texas Sky Jones
quand il arrive katers
OK et Mac Daniel's Mac Daniel's
mcdaniel's
Asus
alors alors il a même pas de
il a même pas de page wikipédia de
McDaniel c'est triste
ah non tu as pas fait Elvis tu as fait
quoi Washington
tu as fait quoi ah San Diego Steve en
plus
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe il a joué un
steak comme Tony Snell voilà je laisse
des infos comme ça non n'importe quoi
pas ton snap du tout comme notre ami
koween hard bon bah écoutez tu aurais
une erreur et leur Kubo le cas où est-ce
que tu as joué Walid Chanel
est-ce que tu as joué est-ce que tu as
joué Annecy
non Bilbao Bilbao Bilbao Bilba ok oh
ouais ouais ouais ouais
je te disais je déconneries
Tony Snell c'est New Mexico Lobos comme
Cameron burthro Legends NBA bon bah
écoutez
on aura fait on aura fait un 15 sur 16
je vais regarder s'il y a d'autres
joueurs comme ça que j'ai oublié qu'il y
avait pas dans la liste
on aura fait un petit 15 sur 16 écouter
c'est pas trop trop mal parce que il y a
qui qui s'est fait transférer il y a
il y a Messenger qui joue à Juke et il y
a ice Miss et Miss je n'ai aucune idée
je n'ai aucune idée de la fac de
ischmist c'est quelqu'un qui est là
dans le chat bien joué mais là dans le
dans l'état actuel des choses sur les 17
joueurs il y en a enfin ils sont rien à
16 pour les 7 jours il y en a 14 qui
conjoint de Sillé dans 15 jours NCIS
pardon et j'en ai eu 14 donc c'est pas
trop trop mal
bon allez on va partir là-dessus
on va la garder quand même par curiosité
et chemise
tu as dû faire un tout petit programme
universitaire je pense
Wake Forest ah bah alors pas un tout
petit programme universitaire de 2007
2010 ok ok ok ok ok mais époque je ne
suis pas là NCA donc j'avoue que j'avoue
que c'est beaucoup trop difficile pour
moi mais tu as été gentil de me mettre
de me mettre les Hornets parce que c'est
une équipe assez jeune donc je peux m'en
tirer tu m'aurais sorti les Lakers de
tes foutu franchement
et les cœurs c'est janvier sans que
c'était un miracle donc
donc voilà bon ben écoutez merci à tous
merci à tous d'avoir suivi ce live on se
retrouve normalement
vendredi soir voilà moi mes actes sur la
semaine bah écoutez je vous ai sorti je
ne sais pas si vous l'avez vu ou non je
vous ai sorti un petit live un petit
lave un petit trade aujourd'hui le pivot
de Memphis donc si jamais ça vous
intéresse vous allez chambre Twitter
Luger Kaya et puis vous pouvez voir ça
vous avez tous les tous les trades
possible donc voilà vous allez sur le
mon twitter et vous pouvez voir ça de
mercredi soir je tourne avec
tigrouchnier Titouan de pour le podcast
s'appelle room de Celtics France on va
pas parler d'un joueur que les Celtics
quadrater au second tour donc je suis
hyper content de tourner avec lui c'est
vraiment très cool et vendredi du coup
on se voit en live je fais des bisous à
tous prenez soin de vous
et vous bien passé une bonne semaine bon
courage pour tous ceux qui travaillent
tous ceux qui étudie etc faites
attention à la santé et puis on se voit
tout bientôt ciao à tous bonne soirée